[Musik]
richtig
med
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so verließ
weil es heute gibt es ein richtig cooles
rezept ich habe hier eine pizza blume
und farbe steht dieser diplome aus
kleinen kicker brötchen diesen gefüllt
mit produkt und im innern habe ich noch
richtig tollen blick und ein cover
praktisch einfach von brötchen abreißen
in winterthur einzuhauchen und brötchen
essen aber auch kein besteck und kein
geschirr dafür richtig cooles fluten
übertreiben
und ja ich bin richtig genial lebkuchen
menschen auf den riesen ein jahr zeit
ein bisschen zu früh aber das macht gar
nicht mit dabei heute weiß man noch
nichts dann überleg dir das mag und ich
zeige euch in der zwischenzeit zumal die
daten für den pizzateig ich auch für den
pizzateig frau ist 450 gramm mehl einen
viertel des wertes in zehn gramm eines
löffel zucker habe ich 250 milliliter
wasser einen halben teelöffel salz
pfeffer und drei esslöffel olivenöl
ich kenne den hefeteig ist in der
küchenmaschine abwickeln denn auch gerne
mit der hand kneten
ich werde zuerst einmal das meer
eingeben dann löse ich die hefe mit dem
zucker im wasser auf
dann kommt die mischung hiermit abhob
gemeinsam mit den restlichen zutaten
sind findet immer ganz lecker im hilfe
zeigt jetzt lasse ich den teig etwa 17
minuten lang
der teig ist genügend geknetet jetzt
nehme ich ihn heraus ich habe ein
bisschen olivenöl auf der arbeitsfläche
vom den teig zu einer kugel und dadurch
wieder mit dem öl bis hin zu stricken
und trocknet vom aufgehen nicht aus der
computer nie wieder rein und darf dann
für etwa 60 minuten aufgeben
während der pizzateig jetzt noch aufgeht
kann ich schon mal die füllung zu
bereiten und dafür danke ich euch mal
die zutaten für die füllung brauche ich
200 gramm etwas schlafen oder etwa 100
kam habe ich noch einen kaffee voller
schmelz eigenschaft wenn ich etwas
verwirrt kommen nämlich verschiedene
kräuter die minze schnittlauch koriander
basilikum und petersilie hier etwas
druck für den natürlich salz pfeffer und
chili und zum bestreichen habe ich einen
teelöffel trauben viel druck mit einem
esslöffel wasser vermischt
bundesversammlung bestreuen wir zuerst
einmal die kräuter und werden jetzt ein
hackl
falls ihr eine küchenmaschine habt dann
könnt ihr die kräuter natürlich auch
hier oben in seinem posten und auch den
käse fein reiben
aber ich mache der freund einfach mal
auf die altmodische variante mit dem
messer
[Musik]
die kräuter gebe ich jetzt in eine große
schüssel
da kommt jetzt das schmandt mitreden
das canon kamera und ihr könnt ihn franz
liebkind füllung rein machen was sie
möchte
er stand dort für die cremigkeit das
schafft käse gibt ein bisschen die würze
und der kaffee käse den wir auch gerne
zum überbacken
er sorgt dafür dass später dieser tipp
einfach zu schön zum streitpunkt hat und
einfach schön du kannst du kannst uns
mal helfen
morath was ich schreibe noch kurz bringt
hilfe wird fein gerieben
doch lieber ich wegen den fingern
[Musik]
und ich schreibe lang den anderen käse
käse kommt dazu und weitere jetzt
stecken wir gleich mal auf und wir noch
ein bisschen brauchen aber damit man
vorsichtig sein der schafskäse hatte
schon genug geschmack kann sein dass er
gar kein salz benötigt oder nur ganz
wenig kultur weiter erklären bisschen
auf
[Musik]
jetzt ist auch der hefeteig schön auf
gegangen und ich hätte jetzt meine
arbeitsfläche mit strom und gibt den
takt vor drauf super flanke mannschaft
[Musik]
immer probiert jetzt profitieren würde
optionen noch keine kugeln jetzt erstmal
so ist weiten wir die aus ihr könnt
jetzt einmal ohne füllung machen oder
mit schulungen aber natürlich werden wir
die jetzt mit füllung machen und zwar
mit einer rein gar nicht so groß
aufhalten und ein bisschen wachsen aber
schön gleichmäßig zwei scheiben an
[Musik]
jetzt umdrehen dann mache ich die so und
du machst eine flugreise nach kugel
direkt übereinander lachen
sacramento verlangsame mit 48 große
brötchen gemacht aber ihr könnt auch 16
kleine machen was ich auch sehr viel
finde ich werde diese pizza backblech
nehmen und weil ich hab den big plays
reihen gebe dann unten hier aus den
löchern rauschten könnte muss natürlich
ein backpapier dazwischen und
zerschneiden falte ich so einen kleinen
schluck müttern schultüte dann legt man
schon titel dann legt man sich das vom
mittelrhein gut wenn man kann man so
auch warum schneiden cooler typ und wir
packen das jetzt nicht tun sondern
blumen für mich aber wir können zum
beispiel auch eine springform nehmen
oder eine runde backform ich verletzt
war heute backformen witze mit der
schmidt konnte nach unten jetzt nehme
ich hier das gemisch auf trauben werup
und wasser das bringt einen schönen
glanz und sondern leicht süßlichen
geschmack kompletter schön drauf
gestrichen
[Musik]
ich werde das ganze jetzt noch schön
ausgehen lassen damit die brötchen
richtig schön fluffig werden ja ich sag
doch wohl aber mit in der mitte sicher
keine pflicht schlief wenn sie etwas
reinlegen and medium gehst du warst du
im garten nach dem entsprechenden
beschluss habe und wo wir jetzt hier zum
beispiel umgedreht natürlich oder ich
mache wird ein bisschen einfacher ich
nehme den kleinen tortenring unglück
denn hier ein liegt jetzt echt nicht
ganz so lange es noch mal für etwa 360
60 minuten auf bakulin mitrechnen
aufgegangen
entferne ich den ring ganz vorn gesteckt
und da kommt jetzt in die methodik
stellung ein
versprechen habe ich sehe schon jetzt
porto entwicklung auf die brötchen drauf
man könnte schon gebacken bekommen wird
in den vorgeheizten backofen bei 200
grad ober unterhitze für etwa 30 bis 35
minuten fertig gestellt braun werden
noch nicht durch sind schaltet einfach
die temperaturen jetzt ist die pizza
blume fertig habe den rahmen entfernt
einfach mit dem backform metern noch mal
durchmachen
deswegen nehme gern kaffee mit rain man
nur der kaffee bewegt das tier passiert
und vor allem karl ecker möchte ich
probieren herzhafte war aber wie luftig
nur wer hat das schon hart an meinem arm
machte nochmal nein mach mich lieber
nochmal auf mega frisch so lecker werden
alle hunger und amira gefällt dir auch
mal probieren beim papa aber probieren
möchte dann bereitet doch einfach mal
selbst los geht wirklich super einfach
und ganz schnell eigentlich oder ja
genau und die kräuter könnte auch
variieren
den gibt's so machen wie ihr möchtet ich
werde persönlich noch ein bisschen mehr
eingeben nicht assimilieren nimmt findet
ihr auf verlag.de also viel spaß beim
nachmachen bewegt normalverteilung
machen
am morgen hat einhorn
[Musik]